welcome to another one of my dr.
Sadler's honest book reviews and the
book that I am examining this time is
the porch and the cross ancient stoic
wisdom for modern Christian living by
Kevin vhost it's also coming out with an
Jellicle press and as you can guess from
the title there's going to be a lot of
comparison connection contrasting
ancient stoic philosophy and Christian
thought and practices both in terms of
modern Christianity but also in terms of
early and medieval
particularly scholastic Christianity so
vhost is a longtime author this is you
know one of his many books and I'm a
whole I think it's quite good I was glad
that I was sent a copy it's it's
interesting to read I will say that in
my view it's probably going to be for
certain types of audiences so so those
who are receptive to seeing some sort of
connection between philosophy and
Christian thought and practice so those
who think that you know Christianity by
itself or religion in general is
complete bunk it's probably not a book
for you those who on the other hand
think that you know any tincture of
philosophy destroys Christianity or
faith well then this probably isn't for
you at all unless you're open-minded
enough to read a work that is making a
case for that but I think for for most
people that are interested in stoicism
or in in Christianity there's gonna be
something in this work that you'll find
worthwhile something that will provoke
some thought maybe get you to read
something else so on the whole my review
is is pretty positive and now let's
let's talk about specifics
I always like to begin by talking about
the structure style and other elements
of the works that I'm reviewing so vhost
is an established author he writes quite
well I have you know nothing to say
negative about that as a matter of fact
it's quite enjoyable to read him and I
think most readers will will find that
to be the case as well he is writing not
for academics of course but for ordinary
people I think he rather specializes in
that and he does that that quite well in
terms of the structure of the book he
deliberately set it up so that it's
focused around a set of chapters and a
set of authors so the authors that he's
going to look at our four classic stoic
figures the ones who we have the most
writings from begins with Missoni office
then he goes to epictetus and then he
talks about Seneca and then he brings it
to a close by looking at marcus aurelius
so makes perfect sense that he would
look at these four authors these are the
ones that most people studying stoicism
are going to encounter before they might
get into reading other other authors who
either are not themselves stoic but but
are telling us very important things
about stoicism like Cicero or Galen or
Plutarch or reading other stoic authors
in fragments so what we have here are
these these four big authors and there's
three chapters devoted to each of them
the first of which is a life chapter so
it's a short biography and I do mean a
short biography interesting stuff most
is you know good at researching you're
not going to find anything in here where
you're gonna you're gonna say I don't
think that's right but you know these
are pretty short they're they're they're
they're workman like they're there to
get across you know the tenor and the
you you could say the context of the
person's life where most is putting more
attention and and I would say you know
more
of a treatment of it are in the lessons
chapters and then the legacies chapters
now the lesson chapters for the most
part are excerpted or summarized from
the works of these authors so he he's
doing exactly what he calls it he's
showing us what the lessons are that
these four philosophers have to to
impart about you know daily life about
relationships about you know freedom
about how we ought to think of ourselves
desires of versions all all these sorts
of things and then he has an interesting
legacy chapter and each legacy chapter
talks in part about the connection
between these stomache of authors and
and other sometimes Christian authors or
certainly Christian practices doctrines
the way of life and tries to connect
them together but he also does talk
about other stoic authors and even other
authors in the mix that that are quite
interesting it's a bit rather selective
but we'll get to that when we talk about
the the key themes as far as the I mean
you can tell that it's not a very long
book it's about 188 pages total so it's
a fairly quick read I would say you know
some of the chapters are as short as
just a few pages some of them are a good
bit longer and you know you you probably
could read it in sections just read say
the mousou Gnaeus or just read the the
marcus as you know shorter selections
like if you're going to teach this it
could be useful for that or if you had a
book group so that's the structure you
know the style like I said very readable
I think it's well argued well researched
yeah quite quite interesting and and
good presentation of things here
alright now let's talk about the key
themes or the key ideas of this work and
so as I mentioned it really breaks down
into four main sections there is a very
short author's preface where he tells us
about you know why he was writing it on
the nature of this book how you might
you know use it and then there is a sort
of wrap up at the end conclusion
bringing stoic wisdom and Christian love
into our world today talking about you
know the the idea of Spiritual Exercises
which i think is is quite important and
is a way in which christianity and
stoicism can be compared and in which I
think arguably stoicism has in fact
influenced at least some Christian
thinkers sometimes they knew it
sometimes there's a stoic legacy that
that they're just sort of inheriting so
let's talk about Musso Gnaeus the the
person who we have the the least about
that's the first person that he
discusses he talks about his life then
he goes on to you know summarize his his
lectures and really some of the key
themes in in in boasts view are the
duties and joys of family life that's
that's front and center he dwells quite
a bit on connections between Missoni
is's views on sexuality and and marriage
and how we ought to use our bodies and
and you know similarities with with
christian morality he also talks about
philosophy as training which which is
right there I mean Musso Gnaeus thinks
that philosophy is primarily practical
there are some theoretical aspects of
but those are subordinated to that and
then he also talks about Missoni is's
insistence which is you know quite stoic
goes all the way back to Zeno on
equality in our treatment of people
according to gender so you know mo
Sonia's had stressed that women and men
need to have the same kind of virtues
they both should study philosophy
and so it vhost drives that home and in
the the legacy part you know he he talks
a bit about you know
Epictetus and you know how this is going
to fit in because erroneous is of course
Epictetus is teacher and you know you
can see a lot of connections like i said
between Missoni is's views on ethics and
and christian morality
Epictetus is given a much longer
treatment which makes perfect sense
because we we have more of epictetus
--is works so we know a lot more about
his thought and he has had a much
greater impact I would say outside of
just the sphere of stoic philosophy on
philosophy in general he endorses long
who's a major stoic scholar longs you
know statement that that there's really
four key themes and epictetus freedom
judgment volition and integrity there's
some good discussion of each of those
there although rather short he also
discusses epictetus --is that epictetus
is notion as such because he is getting
it from other Stoics but we don't see it
in any other Stoics that we have of the
three disciplines or toe poi you know
desire desire and aversion of course
choice and rejection and ascent or
descent as vhost is putting it here and
he's got a you know proper treatment of
that he looks at a lot of the other key
themes that we see a rising in epictetus
being in control or not in control
there's a nice discussion of pry racist
which is another key idea I'm not sure
that I would go with
vhost on endorsing calling it the will
but you know he's getting that from from
long so that makes sense a lot of
discussion of death and duties
developing character he's drawing
primarily on the enchiridion which i
think again in a book of this size makes
sense and then there's a long discussion
of Epictetus as legacy which you know
again I think makes makes a good sense
in part because if we look at all the
people
Epictetus has in fact influenced you
know ranging from lip seus the the neo
stoic
to Admiral Stockdale - cognitive
behavior therapy and rational emotive
behavior therapy
all this sort of stuff it really it
really does fit and it helps to to round
that out he also has a great discussion
about how Epictetus himself was
Christianized in his text and and a
little bit of snippets of what that
looks like
then we get to Seneca and there's a
variety of themes from the letters being
discussed in the Seneca section let's
see I'll just read you a few of these
I'm not gonna try to summarize all of
them how to read books wisely how the
philosopher deals with popular culture
needless fears a sound mind and a sound
body philosophy is not spoken but lived
you know the stuff that you will find in
Senecas letters and of course Seneca
wrote a lot so vhost has to do a bit
more summarizing here and he discusses
the fact that Seneca has two sides two
ways people viewed him because Seneca in
his biography if you know we think about
this he was a rich man he did have
access to power he doesn't appear to
have been particularly effective in
getting Nero to not be a bad guy some
people view him as what votes calls an
opportunist politician others stress the
other side of Seneca being a lover of
wisdom trying the best that he can and I
think votes does does a good job in
pointing out that look both of these
could could be true
there are a lot of connections between
Seneca and the early church and vhost
highlights those which i think is quite
good he also discusses other you know
later receptions of Senecas ideas and
there's more discussion here of a very
interesting figure lip sis who's a
renaissance neo stoic or you know
reformation really so he that that
that's worth looking into and then we
finish up with with Marcus I like the
the title for the first chapter
gratitude 101 you know
that's quite clever I was at vhost as is
good at naming these things giving them
contemporary titles and he talks about
each of the 12 books of Aurelius
meditations you know the work of a human
being the beauty of the universe don't
turn into a Caesar throwing away the
bitter pickle these are all sort of
common themes that you see in in Marcus
and and vhost gives you a good treatment
of these there's also an interesting
discussion towards the end of the Marcus
section of the at that time
stoicism today organization now it's
it's called modern stoicism and the blog
is still retaining the title stoicism
today so that's that's part of what he's
discussing there and them as I mentioned
he closes the book with a few
reflections on Spiritual Exercises in
stoicism and in Christian authors so
that is really in a nutshell what the
book is going to tell you about
on the whole I like this book quite a
bit and I think it could be very useful
for a number of people it does what it
aims to do and it doesn't try to do more
than that which which is kind of a good
thing and in a book as an author myself
I can tell you there's a temptation
always trying to add more stuff in
there's a you know a lot of good
surveying of the available scholarship
and literature as I mentioned before Voz
else knows what he's talking about and
he he brings together a lot of threads
another thing that I really do like
about the book so it's officially
focusing on four stoic thinkers but
you're going to get introduced to
several others stoic sand and non Stoics
and so there's a lot of you know good
discussions of those short but they're
sort of threads that you can pick up if
you want to follow them out you know
whether it's Cicero who's not a stoic
but it's helping us to understand the
Stoics or lip seus or you know here at
Cleese there's there's a enough meet
there that I think it it helps the
reader understand how these things come
together and I'll say another good thing
too
there's no conflation of well this is
one person saying this so we can
automatically read it in to somebody
else which is sometimes a problem with
with literature come you know combining
the different Stoics so it offers a lot
of good starting points there's
interesting comparisons being made in
terms of stoicism and Christianity makes
good sense because it is the porch and
the cross so it's about those those two
and I would say that the book as a whole
is well organized it's it's well put
together as I mentioned you could just
read you know those three chapter chunks
independently of each other I think they
do gain as a whole as a composition so
those are the things that I thought were
good about the work
there wasn't a lot that I found
particularly problematic in this work
where I thought that the reader might
get actually miss ladder there's no
place where I think there's any
misinformation being given I will say
something about two points one is early
on in the book where vhost is discussing
stoicism and in particular Zeno and
framing it in terms of being influenced
by the lives and lessons of two earlier
Greek Socrates himself and the founding
father the cynics Diogenes of Sinope and
you know it's controversial whether
Diogenes should be called the founder of
the cynics there is some scholarly you
know precedent for it but but I
personally think antis tonie's really
does deserve the title better that there
is a continuity there so a probably you
know could be a little bit misleading
but it's not anything that's that's
that's you know really bad the the issue
is though that the cynics are a Socratic
school and Zeno is is not just
influenced by Socrates he's influenced
by the cynic Socrates by the you know
Platonic Socrates by Xenophon's account
of Socrates and by the megarians because
he studies with these these three
different philosophical schools Andy
Reid's Xenophon so I think that that
could have been a little bit better
handled but that's a that's a pretty
minor quibble the other thing that I
have to say has to do with history and
it has to do more with with the
transition from stoicism to Christianity
I'd say that that vhost is really good
at talking about early Christians he's
great at talking about Thomas Aquinas
and you know people following that
including Dante I think that part of the
story that does get left out in talking
about you know how how these texts get
get passed on is the monastic and
he does talk about how the Christianized
version of Epictetus is taxed you know
we'll have the anchorite instead of the
philosopher that that's that's good but
you know you know that the treatment of
well here and marked it actually Seneca
right
we know that Seneca was incredibly
important as with Cicero for monastic
writers it's not just you know jump from
the patristic age which is the age of
early early Christianity the first you
know say six seven centuries all the way
into the scholastic age and I kind of
understand where that's that's probably
coming from so that's kind of a quibble
on my part and that's because I do work
on monastic thank yours but so I think
that that that I'm not saying it's a
detriment to the work I'm just saying
that it's it's something that's left out
of the story and and I think what this
comes down to really is that this is a
book which is you know it's definitely
not designed for scholars although
scholars can read it it's designed for
the ordinary person who doesn't have a
lot of background in in this material
who you know will come away and knowing
quite a bit more and will understand you
know a lot of the connections between
ancient stoicism and Christianity
including modern Christianity so a few
quibbles but not a lot negative to say
about the work
all right so my parting thoughts on this
work I'm actually a fan I would
recommend this to people I enjoyed
reading it it's it's you know good even
as somebody who does a lot of work on
stoicism and on Christian thinkers it's
good for me to get reminders of things
once in a while and you know vhost does
know his stuff so so I I think it was
good
III don't know that like I mentioned
people who are really uninterested in in
religion or Christianity or who view
philosophy as a threat to faith are
gonna get much out of the book but
that's not most people I would suppose
so so I think that this could actually
be quite good for a lot of people I
could see here's probably my biggest
endorsement of it I think this would be
equally useful for people in small
groups studying stoicism as it would be
for people in small groups studying
Christianity and that's that's kind of a
hard balance to pull off so on the whole
I give it a solid recommendation and
very happy that I got to review this
you